sie sind die ersten im einsatz die
piloten der flugzeugträger geschwader
ring
er will dafür die fast jede erdenkliche
mission aussehen
70 flugzeuge unterschiedliche typen
stationiert auf einem flugzeugträger
da ist kein platz für allein
das ist enorm komplexe
an der spitze des geschwaders die
jagdbomber f a 18 hornet und super
hornet
ziemlichen schaden anrichten
die flieger der navy mussten sich erst
im kampf beweisen
da konnten wir zum ersten mal zeigen
dass die geschwader eine eigenständige
angriffswaffe heute spielen die er im
geschwader eine entscheidende rolle über
den us-streitkräften
unseren 1 600 es um leben
[Musik]
frühjahr 2016 im persischen golf
die besatzung des flugzeugträgers uss
truman bereitet eine ehe vineyard bombay
staffel für einen kampfeinsatz vor
der ziel
die im irak die hauptstadt der provinz
al anbar wird von es milizen
kontrolliert
die harry truman soll ihnen einen
vernichtenden schlag versetzen mit ihrer
schlagkräftigsten waffe der träger
staffel vi
die carrier ehring setzt sich aus 70
marinefliegern zusammen
hubschrauber
frachtmaschinen
jets für die elektronische kampfführung
und 48 jagdbomber der typen f a 18
hornet und
super hornet
wir haben vier angriffs staffel mit f a
18 eine staffel mit f a 18 hornet für
diese hilfe eines
dann haben wir drei staffeln mit f a 18
super hornet sie bilden die speerspitze
und werden ein gesetz für den luftkampf
oder für den angriff auf bodenziele
zielgenau pünktlich und immer bereit
die jagdbomber sollen den einsatz im
irak durchführen
sie haben waffen mit enorme
durchschlagskraft damit sollen sie eine
wichtige einnahmequelle des zerstören
von unserem geheimdienst haben wir die
information dass die e s kämpfer einer
zementfabrik unter kontrolle damit
verdienen sie hunderttausende dollar den
ihre organisation fließen
daher wurde beschlossen diese fabrik als
einnahmequelle zu zerstören
es gibt aber ein problem die fabrik
steht mitten in einem dorf in dem viele
zivilisten leben
die piloten müssen extrem vorsichtig
sein
um einen kollateralschaden möglichst zu
vermeiden greifen wir mitten in der
nacht an zu dieser zeit erwarten wir die
geringste anzahl an zivilisten in der
umgebung
kurz vor mitternacht ist es soweit
russell brown und neun weitere piloten
starten ihre triebwerke
dann steigen die jagdbomber in den
nachthimmel
brown und die anderen piloten wissen die
dunkelheit bietet ihnen keinen schutz
sobald sie über dem irak sind sind sie
in höchster alarmbereitschaft
der assist in besitz von abwehrraketen
die er gegen uns einsetzen könnte
[Musik]
wir fliegen so hoch wie wir können um
außerhalb ihrer reichweite zu bleiben
kurz vor ihrem ziel müssen die kampfjets
noch einmal auftanken
darum wartet über den wolken ein
tankflugzeug der us airforce
wir verbrauchen rund 4800 lukaku rosinen
er stünde eine tankfüllung reicht nicht
für die strecke vom flugzeugträger im
persischen läuft bis zum zielort im irak
und zurück
[Applaus]
[Musik]
eine kc 135 soll für nachschub sorgen
braun nähert sich dem ausleger des
tankflugzeugs über den seine maschine
betankt werden soll jedes mal ein
kritisches manöver
ich bin dabei immer etwas nervös
schließlich ist das eine kollision mit
einem anderen flugzeug in der luft wenn
auch eine kontrolliert weg
wenn man da nicht ruhig und präzise
arbeitet endet das in einer katastrophe
das auftanken dauert zum glück nur
wenige minuten
ein voller tank reicht für zwei stunden
genug um das ziel zu erreichen
und wieder zurückzufliegen
der einsatzplan sieht vor dass sich die
kampfjets erst kurz vor dem ziel sammeln
um dann gemeinsam zuzuschlagen
wer ist
der feind soll uns nicht bemerken bis
wir am ziel angelangt sind
die terror miliz es hat wachposten
aufgestellt die rund um die uhr ausschau
halten wenn sie die jagdbomber vorzeitig
entdecken könnte dies auch fatale folgen
für die zivilbevölkerung haben
wir haben immer sorgen dass der feind
ins entdeckt wer weiß wie er denn
reagiert
vielleicht bringen sie zivilisten und
zielgebiet um uns vom bombenabwurf
anzuhalten
es wäre nicht das erste mal dass der esc
die listen als menschliche
schutzschilder missbrauchen würde wie
sollen die piloten in so einem fall
reagieren
kämpfer zu tun damit kann ich leben aber
unschuldige zivilisten zu legen das will
ich noch
brown und die anderen piloten nähern
sich dem ziel und sammeln sich zum
angriff
instrument diese zementfabrik war
ziemlich groß wir hatten mehrere
zielpunkte festgelegt die wir dort
treffen wollten
der auftrag lautet die fabrik komplett
zu zerstören
der esl keine chance haben mit resten
weiter zu produzieren
meint hatte vier bomben des typs gbu 31
an bord jede mit rund 900 kilogramm
gewicht diese bomben steuern mit gps
präzise ihr ziel an
browns super hornet soll die erste bombe
abwerfen
der jagdbomber hat elf aufhänge
vorrichtungen für bomben und raketen mit
einem gesamtgewicht von bis zu acht
tonnen
wir können eine vielzahl von luft luft
und luft boden waffen mitführen das
macht die super hornet so vielseitig
einsetzbar
für den einsatz im irak wurden die super
hornet mit gps gelenken bomben bestückt
den gpu 31
die super hornet kann sprengköpfe
verschiedener größe mit sich führen
normalerweise liegen die bomben an bord
jeweils zwischen 250 und 1.000 kilogramm
wichtiger noch als ihre größe ist die
zielgenauigkeit der bomben
dank der gps steuerung welche sie vom
vorgegebenen ziel um maximal 13 meter ab
die super hornet kein ziemlichen schaden
anrichten werden
zurück zum einsatz im irak
kapitän leuten und braun nimmt sein ziel
ins visier
bislang scheinen die wachposten der e s
kämpfer keinen verdacht zu schöpfen
sicher gehen
und dann die bomben möglichst schnell
werfen bevor sich die situation am boden
die piloten sind bereit jetzt kommt
alles auf das perfekte timing an
wir sind die enten nacheinander im
einminütigen abständen
würden wir alle bei uns rechtzeitig
abwerfen sind könnte die explosion den
anderen piloten die sicht auf ihre ziele
das heißt aber auch die piloten haben
weniger als eine minute um ihre bomben
abzuwerfen und wieder sicher weg zu
kommen bevor die nächste super horn ihre
kunden löst
raum für den angriff an
wenn er sein ziel verfehlt wäre die
ganze mission gefährdet
brown setzt zum angriff an
er zieht die super hornet hinunter und
wirft rund dreieinhalb tausend kilogramm
bomben ab
ich spürte in dem augenblick wie die
flügel
vibrierte nervös darauf dass die
ein punktgenauer treffer
die neuen anderen f a 18 folgen
als sich der staub legt bis das ergebnis
klar
auftrag erfüllt fabrik zerstört
die er wegen einheiten der uss truman
setzen ihre angriffe drei monate lang
fort
die piloten fliegen über 2000 einsätze
gegen stellungen des e s
dabei werfen sie mehr bomben ab als
jemals zuvor in einem auslandseinsatz
wir haben den es dadurch entscheidend
geschwächt
natürlich bin ich ein bisschen stolz
darauf mit dazu beigetragen zur hand
ich hoffe dass die ds cam verloren
wissen dass wir immer über ihren köpfen
kreisen und sie keine chance haben sich
bei uns zu verstecken oder wegzulaufen
wir machen unseren job einfach gut wir
finden und töten ich hoffe sie merken
dass ihre lage hoffnungslos ist ihre
zeit ist abgelaufen
genau das ist die aufgabe der träger
staffeln die unbeschränkte überlegenheit
der usa im luftraum zu sichern
[Musik]
nicht zuletzt um bei internationalen
krisen schnell eingreifen zu können
mit ihren flugzeugträgern und deren
fliegenden einheiten können die usa an
praktisch jedem ort der welt militärisch
eingreifen
seit mehr als 70 jahren stehen sie im
zentrum der amerikanischen strategie
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
waren kriegsschiffe enorm wichtig denn
herr papa in einer zeit ohne radar gps
und satelliten gab es ein großes problem
man wusste nicht wo genau
so entstand die idee mit flugzeugen den
feind zu ordnen um ihn dann gezielt zu
bekämpfen waren
im ersten weltkrieg übernehmen die
flugzeuge der us marine eine weitere
aufgabe sie werfen bomben ab
mehr als 30 feindlicher u-boote geraten
in ihr visier
am anfang des krieges hatte die us
marine 54 flugzeuge am ende des krieges
waren es fast
stücke für die lufthoheit und
luftüberlegenheit gewannen immer mehr an
bedeutung
man immer noch die kriegsschiffe für
entscheidend aber man wollte auch den
luftraum darüber sicher
1922 sticht der erste flugzeugträger der
vereinigten staaten in see die uss
langley kurz darauf folgen zwei weitere
die uss lake sinken und die usa
[Musik]
doch unter den admiralen entsteht ein
disput wie die flugzeuge an bord
eingesetzt werden sollen
es gab zwei ansichten die einen wollten
sie zur aufklärung und ordnung
feindlicher ziele einsetzen während
andere die flugzeuge als eigenständige
kampfeinheiten nutzen
in der zeit zwischen den weltkriegen
testet die us-marine neue kampf
strategien
jedes jahr stand ein großes manöver mit
der gesamten flotte an die manöver
ließen flotte problem
1929 führt die marine das manöver
flotten problem 9 durch die piloten
ergreifen die chance und stellen ihr
ganzes potenzial unter beweis
dieses manöver ging in die geschichte
der marine luft war vereitelt die stadt
im verbund mit den langsamen
kriegsschiffen zu bleiben gibt der
flugzeugträger eigentlich ständig an und
zwar indem er seine flugzeuge an den
luftschlag durchführen muss
ein voller erfolg
die schiedsrichter erklären den sieg der
marineflieger
dennoch werden flugzeugträger weiterhin
als versorgungsschiffe eingesetzt die
die kriegsflotte unterstützen sollen
während in der us-marine über die rolle
der flugzeuge diskutiert wird entwickelt
japan seine eigenen flugzeugträger
bald wird die welt erkennen wie
verheerend ihre schlagkraft ist
siebte dezember 1941 pearl harbor auf
hawaii
sechs japanische flugzeugträger bringen
sich in stellung und starten einen
überraschungsangriff auf die usa
pearl harbour ist der welt
die japaner haben es sehr gut verstanden
die flugzeugträger und ihre fliegenden
verbände als effektive waffe einzusetzen
eigenständig und unabhängig
wir sprechen von einem angriff mit 300
flugzeugen genauestens geplant und
ausgeführt von flugzeugträgern aus
[Musik]
bei dem angriff werden acht
schlachtschiffe der usa stark beschädigt
oder zerstört drei flugzeugträger im
pazifik bleiben aber unversehrt
sechs monate später setzt auch die
us-marine träger kampfflugzeuge ein sie
wartet nur noch auf den richtigen
augenblick zur vergeltung
mai 1942 japan schickt flugzeugträger
und schlachtschiffe vor die nordöstliche
küste australiens
ihr ziel die kommunikationswege zwischen
australien und den usa zu kappen
die us-marine bekommt wind von den
plänen und schickt ihrerseits zwei
flugzeugträger in das seegebiet rund 100
kilometer von den japanischen schiffen
entfernt starten die amerikanischen
kampfflieger
die seeschlacht vor australien ist ein
weiterer historischer meilenstein sind
die furcht es ist die erste seeschlacht
bei der sich die beteiligten
kriegsschiffe nie begegnet
die japaner versenken einen
flugzeugträger der amerikaner
und beschädigen einen anderen
die amerikaner versinken ebenfalls einen
flugzeugträger der japaner
[Musik]
und beschädigen zwei weitere
im prinzip endete die schlacht und in
unser gesunkener träger war größer in
der hinsicht haben die japaner gewonnen
aber sie mussten sich zurückziehen
damit hat die us-marine einen
entscheidenden durchbruch erreicht so
manche historiker sehen in dieser
seeschlacht den wendepunkt im zweiten
weltkrieg siedelten furcht es war das
erste mal dass die japanische marine ihr
ziel nicht erreicht hatte
am ende des zweiten weltkriegs haben die
flugzeugträger mit ihrem luft geschwader
entscheidend zu amerikanischen
vorherrschaft über die weltmeere
beigetragen das ist ein sieg für den
flugzeugträger bis in die 1930 er jahre
hatte noch das schlachtschiff die
führende stellung aber seitdem steht der
flugzeugträger an der spitze doch schon
bald sieht sich die us-marine von einem
neuen gegner herausgefordert und zwar in
der heimat
1947 unterzeichnet präsident harry
truman den national security act es ist
die geburtsstunde der us air force
[Musik]
die airforce erhebt anspruch auf die
mächtigste waffe der welt
die atombombe bequem kalten krieg drehte
sich alles um eine nukleare
die airforce hatte welche die navy nicht
für die airforce sind seestreitkräfte
ein relikt aus alten zeiten
investitionen in schiffe würden sich
nicht auszahlen wir fordern die airforce
leute sagten warum investiert man nicht
stattdessen in den bau von 0 36 bomba
die große nuklearwaffen transportieren
die millionen die man in die marine
investiert kann man sich doch sparen
1949 kündigt das
verteidigungsministerium massive
kürzungen des marine aus als an wie auf
die airforce konnte im ringen um das
budget einiges von der newa abzwacken
damit standen sie flugzeugträger vor dem
aus
er ist ein weiterer krieg zeigt wie
wichtig träger gestützte flugzeuge sind
juni 1950 nach dem angriff nordkoreas
treten amerikanische streitkräfte an die
seite südkoreas um zu verhindern dass
die halbinsel unter kommunistischer
herrschaft welt
unsere truppen hatten ein problem sie
brauchten dringend unterstützung aus der
luft sie konnten den angriffen des
feindes nicht mehr lange standhalten
aber korea liegt außerhalb der
reichweite der air france
damals gab es noch keine luft für die
nächsten air france maschinen waren auf
japan stationiert zu weit weg von korea
tendierte die action in korea und die
b36 mit ihrer atombombe baut auch keine
hilfe was bleibt
in den folgenden jahren haben träger
gestützte kampfflugzeuge einen
entscheidenden anteil daran den
vormarsch der nordkoreanischen
streitkräfte zu stoppen
der krieg endet 1953 mit einem
waffenstillstand jetzt
noch ich denke schon dass der koreakrieg
die marineflieger reiche hätte
tatsächlich
plötzlich stehen die träger gestützten
flugzeuge im vordergrund
in den folgenden 20 jahren wird die
marine fliegerei großzügig gefördert
die us-marine entwickelt flugzeuge für
spezielle aufgaben
langstreckenbomber
aufklärungsbuch schrauber für such und
rettungsaktionen
zum ende des vietnamkriegs verfügt das
fluc geschwader der us-marine über 90
verschiedene maschinentypen eine
logistische herausforderung
wir brauchen unterschiedliche
ersatzteillager herr unterschiedliche
ausbildungslehrgänge gehabt weil wir
unterschiedliche flugzeuge brauchen die
den verschiedensten anforderungen
genügen
das ist nicht so einfach hinzu kommt
dass wichtige flugzeuge der nebel
langsam in die jahre kommen
1973 trifft die us marine eine radikale
entscheidung sie mustert die alten
flugzeuge aus und ersetzt sie durch neue
die flexibler einsetzbar sind sie sind
sowohl für luftkämpfe als auch für
bodenangriffe gerüstet ihren
flugzeugträger haben wenig platz da ist
es sinnvoll wenn ein chat eine mehrzweck
waffe ist
die us-marine entscheidet sich für die
zweistrahlige y f 17
sie ist klein
kostengünstig und mit modernster technik
ausgestattet
was coming in den 1970 jahren nehmen
computer und moderne elektronik
einzelnen waffentechnologien flugsteuer
ein neues zeitalter bricht zusammen
1978 hebt der erste prototyp
das kampfflugzeug für den f 18 hornet
umbenannt
nach fünf jahren ist es voll
einsatzfähig
januar 1991
die uss saratoga liegt im persischen
golf
das flugzeugträger geschwader carrier
air wing 17 mit seinen f a 18 hornet an
bord
der erste einsatz der operation der satz
bei tageslicht steht unmittelbar bevor
[Musik]
die piloten der f a 18 bereiten sich auf
den start vor
sie sollen luftabwehrstellungen des irak
angreifen und außer gefecht setzen
unser ziel war ein gebiet im westen des
iraks und h3 ein flugfeld wir sollten
dort die strategisch wichtigen ziele
ausschalten damit das irakische militär
von dort nicht mehr gegen uns parieren
konnte
[Musik]
doch das gebiet wird von
luftabwehrraketen gesichert eine
ernsthafte bedrohung für die jagdbomber
der us-marine
für einen erfolgreichen schlag braucht
das erwin geschwader fast jedes seiner
flugzeuge
das war eine dieser einsätze bei denen
man vorher wusste das wird hochriskant
man kann nur hoffen dass es gut geht
am frühen nachmittag sind die
kampfflieger des erwin geschwaders 17
bereit für den flug in den irakischen
luftraum
[Musik]
jede maschine hat eine eigene aufgabe zu
erfüllen
eine hockey fliegt voraus sie ist mit
einem frühwarnsystem ausgestattet und
soll das geschwader über mögliche
gefahren am boden oder in der luft
informieren
die technik an bord der hof liegt fast
fünfeinhalb tonnen
damit kann sie ein gebiet von fast
400.000 quadratkilometern kontrollieren
eine fläche wie deutschland und schweiz
zusammen
mit ihrem radar ortet sie auf eine
entfernung von 300 kilometern feindliche
raketen und flugzeuge als nächstes
stärken die f 14 tomcat
die sollen die hornets vor feindlichen
flugzeugen beschützen
[Musik]
dann sind die promis an der reihe sie
sind mit speziellen luft boden raketen
ausgestattet
diese sogenannten horn raketen werden
speziell zur bekämpfung von
bodengestützten radaranlagen eingesetzt
zuletzt starten die vier f a 18 hornet
sie sollen die eigentliche mission
erfüllen die zerstörung des flugfelds
dazu haben sie jeweils vier 1000 kilo
bombe an bord
mit so viel gewicht sind die hornets
nicht mehr so wendig
so hängt das überleben ihrer piloten von
den anderen kampfjets ab
diese unterschiedlichen flugzeuge mit
ihren speziellen aufgaben mussten jetzt
koordiniert werden politiker
bei so einem einsatz lernt man was team
bedeutet
pilot mark fox weiß selbst im verbund
mit den anderen erwin kampfflugzeugen
kann alles passieren
stürzt sich in den kampf ohne zu wissen
wie er enden wird
schon kurz nach dem start erreicht fuchs
den irakischen luftraum
der erste kritische moment
als erstes wie kondensstreifen über uns
auftauchten all countries ziemlich hoch
das war schon ein kleiner schock
doch die kondensstreifen stammen nicht
von irakischen luftabwehrraketen
sondern von den amerikanischen trawlers
tiere raketen abfeuern
wie die raketen sollten die radaranlagen
auf den flug
als ich realisierte dass die raketen
nicht mehr galten und war ich
unglaublich erleichtert
rund 50 km vom ziel entfernt empfängt
fuchs eine durchsage
die hawk eye meldet gefahr
das bedeutete damals
feind im anflug
eine irakische mick steuert auf das
geschwader zu
aber fuchs bleibt gelassen und verlässt
sich auf die tom pätz sie nehmen die mit
ins visier
so was lässt einen nicht kalt aber
gleichzeitig wusste ich ja dass sich die
tom pätz damals ich hatte meine aufgabe
mehr sorgen machten mir die
luftabwehrraketen
schon folgt die nächste warnung der hawk
eye
die hawk eye meldete feinde direkt vor
ihrer nase
eine weitere mit der iraker steuert nur
25 kilometer entfernt direkt auf fox und
seine kameraden zu
das gebiet in dem die mix flogen lag
noch in reichweite der iranischen
luftabwehr
haben unsere tom pätz konnten da nicht
rein um sie auszuschalten es wäre zu
gefährlich gewesen
fox weiß er muss sich auf eine direkte
konfrontation mit der feindlichen mich
einstellen
ich dachte nicht großartig macht die
sache war klar wenn ich meinen auftrag
erfüllen will muss ich sie ausschalten
den 9.000 metern höhe steuert fox mit
seiner f a 18 hornet direkt auf den
feindlichen kampfjet zu ihm auszuweichen
ist nicht möglich
der schoss auch nicht zu nur 15
kilometer entfernt
er flog überschallgeschwindigkeit ich
etwas darunter
fox blieben nur sekunden um die richtige
waffe zu wählen
auf kürzere distanz neben der wärme
suchen des eidg
sie lenken selbstständig zum ziel
ich habe sie im training schon zwei oder
dreimal abgefeuert
dabei entsteht ein großer auf streife
also wartete ich auf den raum
doch nach dem abschuss
so kam kein rauch
fox ist verunsichert und nimmt die mich
erneut ins visier
ich dachte den krieg ich schon noch und
wählte die nächste rakete
als ich den auslöser betätigte gab es
plötzlich eine explosion
die erste rakete hatte doch getroffen
dann ging die spurs und traf ihn an nfl
zu seiner linken wird eine andere mit
von seinen kameraden getroffen
aber die mission ist noch nicht
abgeschlossen die zerstörung des
flugfeldes
als ich das ziel erreichte zog ich den
jet nach unten
ich musste die banken möglichst nah am
boden ab werk
fox löst seine sprengladung insgesamt
4000 kilogramm ihm folgen die anderen
hornets nach wenigen minuten ist das
flugfeld zerstört
[Musik]
er und seine kameraden haben ihre
mission erfüllt und die er vor 18
erfolgreich in einem luftkampf
eingesetzt
[Musik]
die fh 18 hat sich bewährt gemeinsam mit
der ganzen carrier
ich bin nur einer von vielen entstehen
das alleine wäre man verlor
nur gemeinsam kann man eine solche
mission erfüllt
[Musik]
fortan die dfa 18 hornet im zentrum
jedes flugzeugträger geschwaders
ein jahr nach dem golfkrieg stellt die
us-marine eine verbesserte f a 18 vor
die super hornet
sie ist um 20 prozent größer und kann
ein drittel mehr kerosin tanken als ihre
vorgängerin
ihre flügel sind um rund 25 prozent
gewachsen und haben platz für zwei
weitere waffen
die navy entwickelt weitere flugzeuge
auf grundlage der super hornet
2003 bestellt sie den kampf
z18 gegner
mit integrierten stöhr systemen die eine
elektronische kampfführung ermöglichen
fast alle chips der träger geschwader
basieren nunmehr auf der f a 18 hornet
den platz auf einem flugzeugträger der
weit draußen im ozean kreis muss man
effektiv nur ist im sommer
basiert das ganze geschwader auf einem
modell braucht man weniger ersatzteile
und personal
2008 verfügt die us-marine über mehr als
350 neue super hornet und
muster die alten modelle stück für stück
aus
aber sie werden weiter gewartet um in
zeiten des globalen terrors
einsatzbereit zu bleiben
2008 kreuz der flugzeugträger uss
abraham linken im persischen golf seit
zwei monaten bekämpft die carrier air
wing 9 terroristische stellungen
unsere einheiten hatten zwei missionen
zunächst flogen wir im irak bei der
operation
wurden nach afghanistan abkommandiert um
die operation
in den bergen afghanistans staaten
taliban kämpfer immer wieder offensiven
gegen die us armee
im juli 2008 fällt der 500 us-soldaten
in dem krieg
damit ist der afghanistan-konflikt für
die us-streitkräfte
verlustreicher als die kriege im irak
[Musik]
um die bodentruppen besser zu schützen
beschließt die us marine ihre f a 18
hornet nach afghanistan zu verlegen
die kampfjets sollen eingreifen wenn die
soldaten am boden unter beschuss geraten
bei solchen einsätzen muss es schnell
gehen sei es auf ein soldat angeschossen
wurde oder eine patrouille hilfe braucht
heute fliegt christen hanson in einer
zweier staffel die von einem erfahrenen
piloten angeführt wird
die beiden super hornets stärken zu
einem routineflug
sollten die truppen unten am boden nur
mit informationen versorgt
bodenbewegungen sollten würden aufklären
und ihnen mitteilen wo sich der feind
aufhält
henson und ihr staffel kommandeur
überfliegen sechs stunden lang das
gebiet ohne zwischenfall dann ist es
zeit wieder zum flugzeugträger
zurückzukehren
der tag verlief sie nicht ruhig wir
haben für die jungs am boden
aber dann kommen funkspruch ein in dem
hilfe angefordert wurde
irgendwer diesen ball fliegt tage lang
seine sechs stunden einsätze und nichts
passiert und plötzlich ruft dich jemand
weil er dringend hilfe brauchen
ich konzentriere mich nur auf meine
aufgabe cook auf meine instrumente und
pass auf ob am boden gefahr für unsere
truppen lauert
da hat jemand probleme und braucht meine
hilfe
der hilferuf kommt von einer
bodentruppen einheit südlich von kabul
sie steht seit dem morgen und der
beschuss von taliban kämpfern die
jungs hatten herausgefunden woher der
beschuss kam
und baten und die stellung zu zerstören
henson und ihr staffel kommandeur sind
schnell in der nähe der einheit aber
dass taliban versteck auf 15.000 meter
höhe zu entdecken ist nicht so leicht
eine der schwierigsten aufgaben ist es
sicherzustellen dass man das gleiche
ziel anvisiert wieder kontakt mann am
boden
es ist ein problem der perspektiven der
mann am boden schaut sich um und funkt
da ist das ziel und wir da oben im chat
schon runter und antworten prima ich
sehe den bergen welchen meinst du
es geht nicht nur darum das richtige
ziel anzusteuern man muss es auch
treffen
es kann gut sein dass sich befreundete
truppen oder zivilisten in der
unmittelbaren umgebung aufhalten
die piloten und die bodentruppen haben
aber nur wenig zeit sich abzustimmen die
taliban könnten von dem plan wind
bekommen
die bodentruppen gibt die koordinaten
durch und hofft auf einen schnellen
angriff
doch henze hat probleme sie in ihren
computer einzugeben
ich bemerkte dass mein gerät die
zielkoordinaten nicht speichern konnte
es brach den vorgang beim eintippen
immer wieder
die bodentruppen werden immer nervöser
die taliban könnten jeden moment
zurückkehren und sie wieder unter feuer
nehmen
um die taliban stellung zu zerstören
müssen beides super hornets ihre bomben
abfeuern doch hensen kann ihre
technischen probleme nicht lösen dazu
bringt das fühlt sich echt schlimm an
ihr leben stand auf dem spiel und sie
haben sich auf mich verlassen
[Musik]
grenzen muss eine lösung finden den
soldaten am boden bleibt nichts anderes
übrig als auszuharren und in deckung zu
bleiben
15.000 meter über ihnen versucht die
pilotin vergebens ihr defektes ziel an
steuerungsgerät zu rebooten
ich wurde richtig nervös
wir wollten den jungs da unten helfen
und ich hatte diese probleme
das defekte gerät ist zuständig für die
leser gesteuerten werfen die erste wahl
bei solch einem präzisions angriff aber
es gibt noch eine alternative die gps
gesteuerten bomben um sie einsetzen zu
können braucht sie die hilfe ihres
staffel kommandeurs
er konnte die zielkoordinaten der
einheit am boden eingeben und damit das
ziel auch punktgenau identifizieren dann
konnte er die zieldaten an mein flugzeug
die beiden piloten kontrollieren die
koordinaten noch einmal ohne das ziel an
steuerungsgerät muss sich hanson doppelt
absichern
als wir uns hundertprozentig sicher
waren dass wir das richtige ziel
anvisieren und uns auch davon überzeugt
dass keine unbeteiligten gefährdet waren
gab mein vorgesetzter hat das kommando
zum abwurf der bomben
30 sekunden später schlägt die bombe ein
taliban stellung ist zerstört
eine stunde später landen die f a 18
super hornet wieder auf ihren
flugzeugträger
ich erinnere mich noch sehr gut an
diesem tag ich war so glücklich dass wir
unseren kameraden am boden helfen
konnten das war ein tolles gefühl
aber mit der rasanten technischen
entwicklung wachsen auch die bedrohungen
dass er im geschwader muss ihnen
gewachsen leiden
im jahr 2013 stößt das erste unbemannte
kampfflugzeug zur nehme die x47 b drohne
absolviert 37 einsatz flüge von einem
flugzeugträger
vier jahre später
beauftragt die us marine den bau neuer
drohnen diesmal ohne waffen sie sollen
zur luftbetankung der jets eingesetzt
werden
auch auf der liste
80 neue super hornets
und dann der f 35 jäger
kostenpunkt rund 100 millionen euro
das das ist der f 35c lightning to ein
mehrzweck und wahlkampf jäger
der erste törn kappen jäger der auf
einem flugzeugträger stationiert ist
dank ihrer radar absorbierenden
außenhaut kann sich die f35 an ihre
gegner regelrecht anschleichen und sie
kann mit bis zu 8000 kilogramm waffen
ausgerüstet werden
die tankkarten eigenschaften erlauben es
dem piloten in gebiete einzudringen die
für frühere modelle zu gefährlich
gewesen wäre
dieses futuristische kampfflugzeug ist
in vielerlei hinsicht rekordverdächtig
auch was den preis angeht
die f35 ist die bisher teuerste waffe
des us militärs
mit ihr bricht für die carrier air wing
träger geschwader ein neues zeitalter an
viele details über den superflieger sind
bis heute streng geheim
die f35 kann dinge über die wir nicht
sprechen
sie sind schnell
schlagkräftig und flexibel die erringt
reger geschwader sind ein wichtiger
pfeiler der militärischen macht der usa
ob nun im roten meer die indischen ozean
oder im mittelmeer pinien egal wo die
erbin geschwader im einsatz sind
sie fliegen und sie sind erfolgreich das
macht die flugzeugträger so entscheidend
für die streitkräfte
die geschwader mit ihren f a 18
kampfjets haben sich selbst in
schwierigsten kriegseinsätzen bewährt
man muss das schlachtfeld kontrollieren
das meer und dem himmel darüber daran
wird sich nie etwas ändern
die träger geschwader werden wohl auch
in zukunft ihren beitrag dazu leisten